so today I'm going to do everyone's
favorite non-newtonian experiment I'm
going to put this cornstarch and water
solution on this speaker but I want to
do this scientifically so I'm shooting
it with a high-speed camera and I'm
going to vary the frequency and the
amplitude and see what factors really
give us the best cornstarch Monster is
still very much looks like a liquid at
this point but as I increase the
amplitude you can kind of tell that it's
not moving as as smoothly as it should
any more you can see at this amplitude
it starts to jump around a little bit
now I want to try to increase the
frequency and see what effect that has
we are now at about 20 Hertz which is
the frequency recommended by some
scientific papers that have studied this
phenomenon up the amplitude a little bit
that is incredible that is awesome
I'm going up to about 22 hertz seeing
nicer structures but it's really tough
to tell because it's somewhere random
sometimes it just turns into a blob like
that other times you get some really
cool things for me I'm at about 34 Hertz
here and we're not seeing a lot of
structure seems like at these higher
frequencies it just sort of trends into
a blob interesting
they're actually at the higher
frequencies
wow that's interesting in the high-speed
you can clearly see that the inertia of
the thing is keeping it off the speaker
entirely that's really cool so it's just
getting kind of bumped with that
frequency it's not really sticking
around that's why you probably need a
lower frequency
well that's into that
so how do non-newtonian fluids work well
the cornstarch and water is really a
suspension that is these tiny little
grains of starch suspended in water so
when you try to move that fluid slowly
the starch has time to get out of the
way of each other because it's
lubricated by all those water molecules
in between but if you try to get it to
go fast and that is there's a lot of
shear which means there are some places
that are going faster than others well
then all of the starch grains kind of
get stuck up against each other and they
can't flow past each other so at that
point it becomes like a solid unless
like a liquid you know this kind of
reminds me of traffic in LA where I've
been recently if there are not that many
cars on the road it's basically like
having a small amount of starch
particles in your water and everything
flows very smoothly but as soon as you
get to rush hour and you have some cars
but you're trying to floor it down the
highway pluses all of these cars which
are like our starch particles on the
highway
then suddenly everything gets clogged
and you're basically in what is a solid
so traffic might be an example of
something that's a non-newtonian fluid
it flows very well when there aren't
very many particles or when it's going
quite slowly but as you try to increase
the number of cars and go really fast
then everything kind of gets clogged up
you